GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT,
THANK YOU.
>> THANKS.
>> Tucker: FEDERAL JUDGE EMMA
SULLIVAN HAS APPOINTED A RETIRED
JUDGE TO ARGUE AGAINST THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT’S MOTION TO
DISMISS CHARGES AGAINST MIKE
FLYNN.
AND INSTEAD MAKES A CASE FOR
SENDING THEM TO PRISON, FOR
REAL.
JEANINE PIRRO, ALSO AUTHOR OF
THE BOOK "RADICALS, RESISTANCE
AND REVENGE," WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE HER ON TONIGHT.
JUDGE, WHY WOULD THIS JUDGE --
AND IT WAS CONFUSINGLY WORDED ON
MY PART, BUT THIS JUDGE HAS
ASKED ANOTHER JUDGE TO MAKE THE
CASE TO SEND MIKE FLYNN TO
PRISON, WHAT WOULD BE THE
PURPOSE OF THAT GIVEN WHAT WE
KNOW?
>> YOU KNOW, TUCKER, FROM THE
TIME THAT I SPENT ON THE BENCH,
AND IT WAS NOT A FEDERAL BENCH,
BUT IT WAS A TRIAL BENCH AS THIS
ONE IS, IT IS ABSOLUTELY FOREIGN
TO ANY JUDGE TO EVEN CONSIDER
BRINGING IN ANOTHER JUDGE TO
COPILOT A CASE.
UNDERSTAND THIS: THIS IS A CASE
THAT INVOLVES THE GOVERNMENT AND
A DEFENDANT.
THE UNITED STATES, MICHAEL
FLYNN.
THE JUDGE HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
RULE ON THE CASE BEFORE HIM.
IT IS NOT COMPLICATED.
IT IS A MOTION TO DISMISS WITH
ONE OF THE MOST FACTUAL
AFFIDAVIT-LADEN SUPPORT IN TERMS
OF THE EVIDENCE BEHIND IT TO
SUPPORT THE APPLICATIONS TO
DISMISS.
IT’S A MINUTE SERIAL MOVE THAT
THIS JUDGE APPARENTLY DOESN’T
WANT TO MAKE.
SO WE HAVE TO BRING IN ANOTHER
JUDGE, WHO BY THE WAY IS A
CLINTON UP-APPOINTED RETIRED
FEDERAL JUDGE.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE, BECAUSE THE MOTION
MAKES IT CLEAR BECAUSE THERE
WERE MISSING FBI NOTES FOUND OF
THE LAW FIRM WHERE ERIC HOLDER
WAS A PARTNER, AND BECAUSE THE
DEFENDANT, MICHAEL FLYNN, THERE
WAS NO PREDICATE FOR HIM TO BE
INVESTIGATED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
HE WAS TOLD HE DIDN’T NEED AN
ATTORNEY AND THEN WAS DENIED
EFFECTIVE ASSISTANCE OF COUNSEL.
ALL THESE WRONGDOINGS DONE BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
FBI AND THEN NOW, WHAT YOU HAVE
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
SAYING WE WANT TO DISMISS THIS,
WE WANT TO RIGHT A WRONG.
NOW THEY WANT TO BRING IN THE
GROUNDS.
THIS MORNING IT WAS ALL THE
RETIRED WATERGATE ATTORNEYS WHO
WANT TO COME IN AND NOW WE WANT
TO TELL THE JUDGE CHARGEABLE.
>> Tucker: MAY I ASK YOU A
QUESTION?
HOLD ON.
IF YOU TAKE THREE STEPS BACK,
HERE’S A GUY WHO’S GOING TO
PRISON FOR LYING IN A CASE IN
WHICH WE HAVE HANDWRITTEN NOTES
FROM AN FBI OFFICIAL SAYING
SHOULD WE GET HIM TO LIE SO WE
CAN SEND THEM TO JAIL OR GET HIM
FIRED?
IF HE WAS AN ARMED ROBBER I
WOULD DEFEND HIM.
ARE THERE ACTUALLY PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON WITH A STRAIGHT FACE
SAYING HE SHOULD GO TO JAIL?
>> YES, BECAUSE IT HAS BECOME
THE POLITICIZATION OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE SOUGHT IN THE CABIN ON WITH
THE DENIAL OF THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
WE ARE SEEING FURTHER PILLARS
BEING DESTROYED IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE.
>> Tucker: THAT’S RIGHT.
>> THIS DEFENDANT WAS SOMEONE
THAT WAS TARGETED BY THE JUDGE.
THIS JUDGE NEEDS TO RECUSE
HIMSELF, HE SHOULD BE
EMBARRASSED TO PUT A ROBE ON.
HE TELLS THE DEFENDANT WHO IS
FACING FIVE YEARS THE PROSECUTOR
CONSIDER TRYING YOU JUST
CHARGING FOR TREASON, WHICH IS
DEATH PENALTY.
HE SAYS YOU’RE AN AN
EMBARRASSMENT TO THE COUNTRY.
THIS JUDGE DOESN’T BELONG IN
THAT CASE.
AND NOW WHAT HE’S DOING IS HE’S
POISONING THE 2020 ELECTION BY
TRYING TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE
BILL BARR, WAS ONE OF THE MOST
HONORABLE, EFFECTIVE ATTORNEY
GENERALS WE’VE EVER HAD, NOT AN
WING MAN LIKE ERIC HOLDER, HE’S
TRYING TO DESTROY THE WHOLE
THING SO THAT BARR LOOKS LIKE
THE WHOLE VILLAIN HERE.
BY THE WAY, WHAT HAPPENED TO
JOE BIDEN THIS MORNING WAS A
BODY BLOW WITH THE REVEALING OF
HIS BEING ONE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS.
HE’S IN DEEP TROUBLE RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: BUT HE CAN
PLAUSIBLY SAY I DON’T MEMBER.